mom calls me she's like all right I just
went down to the front desk and I was
like did it I was like what took you so
long to get it was like that was like 25
minutes ago she goes yeah I stopped on
every single floor and walked around
every I walked up and down each and
every hallway to make sure your dad
wasn't High sleeping in his underwear
she thought I was in my underwear
walking around the hotel I mean look
granted drugs does do that to some
people but you're not those people
walking around in my underwear you're
you're a pretty professional drug user
thank you like I I will give you your
flowers for sure you're you're a pretty
well-kept
kept together drug user [__] up and
walking around in my underwear that's
not my Mo we are in Phoenix Arizona and
we only had one show on Friday night but
if for those of you who have seen him
live or us live you know that Friday
night late shows he does mushrooms
before he goes on stage proceeds to do
him it's a great time he's way higher
than he thinks he's going to be because
usually you and I have a scale
right so we can weigh out how much he's
going to take he just pulled out a
mushroom and said how much this you
think I should eat and I was like you
should just eat like the upper third of
it and he did and we let it kind of ride
out I ate half you ate more than it I
ate a half of it oh you were definitely
[__] up I that's what me and so on the
drive back first of all the drive back
was great cuz I'm driving me him my mom
and Iman back my girlfriend in this
giant Tahoe and uh I've been telling you
for years or for the last three years at
least that you would love iman's music
taste because it's so eclectic it's got
a little bit of everything but it's all
bangers from all different decades and
she's playing music and the first song
she puts on was uh uh Everybody Wants to
Rule the World and right as it yeah and
right as it went you went you went I
love this
song I do yeah I know it was [__]
awesome I had a Tears for Fears poster
in my room when I was growing up dude
are you kidding me but so uh we uh we
were I were laughing about that when we
got back to the hotel um but we drove
back and and we're all like hanging out
and then we're up in the elevator and I
was like you're going to be up for a
little while aren't you and he was like
yeah probably and then another one of my
favorite parts we were standing in the
elevator and as the elevator started to
go up you lost your balance do you
remember yeah oh yeah and he just like
but he like kind of just like one foot
just kind of fell into the door of the
elevator as we were going up but the
best part was he never lost eye contact
with me so I just watched his face do
this yeah as you like as you drifted it
was like can I tell you the best part
about that guys the big that we're not
getting on this is that legit the only
part of my body that hit the elevator
door was the my head I didn't put my
hands out I didn't duck in with my
shoulder slow fall slow fall and my head
just went GK loud dude you didn't make
your correction I felt like a toddler I
didn't put my hands out or anything oh
my God and so I went up to my room and
we we went our separate ways and uh IID
called you I was like I'm probably going
to go get some food do you want
something and you said nah I'm not
getting up anymore and I was like okay
cool and I went and we got Mellow
Mushroom pizza that night got a buffalo
chicken pizza fire super fire and um a
couple Edibles and I go to bed probably
around
12:30 and I wake up at
2:40 to my girlfriend nudging me saying
hey your Mom is calling me and I was
like what I was like I was like answer
answer answer and she I put her on
speaker and she's like hey I'm like
what's up she goes sorry to wake you um
she's like but and then don't be alarmed
and I was like all right I'm up what are
we talking about she goes but your dad's
not in the
room I was
like I was like what she goes yeah he's
not in bed he's not in in the little
couch Suite area where the TV is either
he's not in the room and I was like all
right hold on let me check my phone and
I checked my phone and the only text or
communication I have from this high ass
man is a text at 1241 a.m. 11 minutes
after I went to sleep that said are you
up and do you have
food and so I immediately I immediately
go well he might have been hungry and
was walk down Mill yeah but then also
I'm not going to lie my brain started to
grow a little bit I was like he is the
weakest human alive when he's high I
hope he didn't walk down Mill by himself
in his Jordan in his Chicago Ones let's
explain as [__] what you mean by that
like my when my dad is high he can't
even open a bag of chips yeah my my
strength is sack his awareness his
social
awareness not well which high my
mushrooms I'm I'm mushrooms you're the
most aware person of all time yeah I'm
I'm also I'm ready to I'm I'm ready to
mingle I'm ready to levels of 10 you're
at a 37 like mushrooms alert alert head
is always on a swivel mainly because
you're [__] walking in circles yeah
on weed no no no social awareness
whatsoever none none and at this time
your mushrooms have worn off and you
were just kind of high on edbl at this
point weren't you I was it was about
50/50 at this point in time but
generally also at that point you're
still that's like a loopy you so you're
still not socially aware of what's no
I'm pretty I was pretty Stony baloney
cuz I was trying to be able to go to
sleep yep and I was like well I hope he
didn't get pushed and somebody took his
food on Mill and also were you just
picturing me laying in the side of the
street yes I didn't know what was
happening but also that was like me at
just woken up my Edibles were still
hitting me like can I ask you a question
the first thing mom said was dad's not
in the hotel room can I ask you a
question no I mean look you're gonna ask
do you really think that you would get
you've now toured with me for a minute
yeah how how am I on drugs do I have my
[__] together you're you're pretty
you're pretty good at it that's that's
why I was like I was like okay well I
was like hold on let me I was like you
she was like I'm GNA go down to the
front desk and see if they had seen him
at any point in time and I go okay
that's a great idea and and then I hang
up and I sit and I call your phone I
probably I could called you probably
about four times in a row hoping that
the constant VI like vibrate would wake
you up or wherever you are I figured you
were sleeping somewhere in the hotel I
was like he's either downstairs on a
couch or he's like he had to have gotten
the second room like there's no other
way like why he wouldn't be in that
hotel sleeping right now doesn't make
any sense and so I called you a bunch of
times and then I was like babe can I
track him she goes does he does he share
his location I go no she goes do you
know his iCloud email and password I go
yeah yeah actually I do she goes how I
go it's my email and password like he
has our original iCloud account was set
up through my email which is why the
dickpic [__] happened ladies and
gentlemen I got roped into that somehow
and tricked Bamboozled you know what I'm
saying win
even
Hood wied especially yeah but so I was
like yeah I actually do know all that
she goes great and she sent me a link to
find my iPhone so I typed in the Apple
ID and iCloud and I was like I'm gonna
track this [__] I'm to see where
he's at and since you didn't have your
precise location on which is a setting
you have to have when I when I brought
it up hey hold on I'm gonna Matt I'm
going to send you the picture that I
took and it was just a circle around the
city of Tempe that said this iPhone is
located somewhere in this area and I was
like well he's still in Arizona so
that's released his phone yeah I was
like well he's still in Tempe I guess
and like like I don't know if like
[__] he'll post it yeah like I like
like this is the picture I got it's just
a circle of the City of Tempe and it's
like yeah I was in there I was in that
Circle and I I sent it to Mom and I was
like well he's still in the city at
least and she just kind of laughed and
then she after I had done all that I it
said there's a button on when you go to
find iPhone that says play sound and so
you can like play it if you find it like
if you're near it it'll play a sound so
you can go find it so I'm thinking again
he's sleeping somewhere so I'm G to play
this sound like an alarm and hope it
wakes him up so I played it I stopped it
I played it I stopped it and then and
then I don't know [__]
probably 10 minutes later or no no 5
minutes later mom calls me she's like
all right I just went down to the front
desk and I was like did it I was like
what took you so long to get it was like
that was like 25 minutes ago she goes
yeah I stopped on every single floor and
walked around every I walked up and down
each and every hallway to make sure your
dad wasn't High sleeping in his
underwear she thought I was in my
underwear walking around the hotel I
mean look granted drugs does do that to
some people but you're not those people
no walking around in my underwear you're
you're a pretty professional drug user
thank you like I I will give you your
flowers for sure you're you're a pretty
well-kept
kept together drug user [__] up and
walking around in my underwear that's
not my M Mo no I'm not GNA do that me
either no no it's that's not that's not
who we are because I'm also old enough
now where I don't put I don't
ingest an amount to make you to that
point and also that sounds like zero fun
no you want to have that memory like no
I'm I'm I'm good you want me to give you
my rundown of the night wait hold up
okay and then five minutes after that I
decided to call my dad again and I
called and on the first ring he picks up
and you were like what's up and I was
like where the [__] are you he goes I'm
in another room I was like what why the
[__] are you in another room he goes it
was really hot in our room and your mom
was sleeping and I couldn't sleep so I
went and just booked another room just
for me to sleep in the night and I was
like all right did you see all the texts
and calls and you were like yeah I I was
getting to it but you called so I
figured I would uh figured I would check
in and I was like why don't you go ahead
and call
Mom and you were like and you were like
yeah yeah I'll do that I go okay I'll
see you in the morning and we hang up
and then I called Mom and I was like I
found him she goes what okay he's
sleeping in another room and she goes
yeah I I I just talked to him I go yeah
I uh she was like
Jacob I am upset with your
father she was like and I was like Mom
and I want to see you have the right
like I get it like to to go to sleep
thinking your husband was there and then
to wake up at 3:00 a.m. and to see him
not there but knowing he just did some
mushrooms and practically could have
fallen out of a moving elevator had the
door been open and he just fell right
into a wall prior to going inside like I
get it like your husband was there and
then he wasn't it was some [__] magic
listen first of all I told her I was
leaving yeah see you said that also and
she responded to me that part I didn't
hear yeah okay let me just tell you my
night first of all it was one of those
Jurassic Park mushrooms oh I was there
um and I was like I'll take it after the
show and I'll be a little high but I
think I should be fine yo on
the on the drive home you know what I I
here's what I can tell mushrooms are
gonna be fun it makes everything kind of
Darker and almost like cocoon for me it
was like and then the everything felt
super cozy and warm it was like I was
walking around in a warm hug it was just
like I was like
Hey and so we're riding in the car the
music was perfect I her Shuffle is good
not Shuffle but her playlist I was it
was honestly one of the best highs I've
ever had that's fun it was so warm and
friendly the music was great and uh we
get back to the
hotel I don't remember a whole lot about
the ride except how much I enjoyed the
music and The Vibes and we get back to
the hotel and um you know we take the
ride up the elevator I I bang my head on
the door pretty good laughing it up I
had a little bruise the next day pretty
funny yeah dude I hit that door hard
yeah it was a light we get back to the
hotel room and I'm laying on the bed the
wrong way like so horizontally to the
vertical oh at the bottom of the bed on
the covers eyes closed eyes closed on
mushrooms is like a whole different your
your brain just takes you wherever you
want to go and I'm just sitting there F
I think a blob face down just VI
complete in my own world
vibing um I think your mom had been
trying to talk to me but I think I was
out in the in the outer space mushroom
land yep when she got into bed I was
such a blob she got into bed and when
she pushed her feet down to the bottom
of the bed it knocked me off the
bed so I [__] FL flop on the
ground I get into bed and I'm like I'm
just going to take some melatonin and
try to power this to sleep so I took
probably 60 milligrams of melatonin
cheapest and uh I'm just getting hot and
a lot I can't you know I'm fidgety in
bed I'm I'm starting to be less
mushroomy you couldn't turn the AC on uh
for whatever reason I was just running
hot I'm getting less mushroomy and more
high on an edible so I'm getting fidgety
the the Melatonin starting to get
there uh I I can't sleep I can't go in
the living room and sleep there's no
blankets in there so I tell your mom I'm
like hey I'm going to go get another
room I got to be able to watch because
she didn't watch want to watch sports
center that's what puts me to sleep yep
dude so I get
downstairs and I and I'm high and I'm
sure I look high right right and I
I I'm wearing the outfit of somebody who
just stole one of everything from
everybody's room dude it is like the
worst hodge podge of I love it and I
walk up to the woman and I go
hey I go I I have a
room but I need another room but just
till tomorrow and you can charge me for
the room but I just need another room to
sleep in
tonight and she goes okay
and she starts
to and she's just typing and typing in
and
and I you know what when you're taking
mushrooms you're not rude or no and I
think I was said a very and weed I go I
go I'm sorry I should have asked are
there rooms
available and she goes will you let me
do my job and I was like uh yeah I don't
like to be chastised when I'm high or
mushrooms I don't like to be chastised
period And I was like oh she was like
it's hard for me to really do my job if
you're just standing here and I was like
what am I supposed to do I was like okay
I'll stand over on that side of the
[__] Lobby so I went and stood on the
dude I because I was high I went and
stood on the other side of the lobby
like I had just been put in
timeout and and then um I was [__] I
was like I don't want to walk back over
there her that lady's that lady's me yo
dude
she but then she looked at me and she
waved me over she goes I'm ready for you
and I was like oh my God and I walked up
to her and she said you can have this
room for free for the night be out of
there by 11:00 a.m. oh and I was like
okay she redeemed herself she felt bad
for when your mom went
downstairs she said to the woman
hey I can't find my husband and the lady
behind the counter goes
wolf
and your mom was like yeah how'd you
know that and she she said yeah I ran
into him earlier
tonight so I'm I'm assuming I slurred it
up a little more than what I just said
to you oh you were probably a very a
very memorable guest oh dude I know for
sure only one of my eyes was working yep
by that time of the night with that many
drugs in my right eye closes plus the
Melatonin oh dud my right eye straight
up Clos you half asleep oh dude I I my
brain was my body was like hey but my
brain was like so when I was asleep in
that room CU Sportsmen Port Sports anim
will put me to sleep in the first Port
Port center port center sort Center sort
Center Sport Center Sport Center will
put me to sleep in the first 105 minutes
I I I find that show to be so boring it
takes less than mostly because and look
man I used to like it a lot but I find
the anchors to be exceedingly boring now
so it's great for sleep and so um I uh I
fall
asleep and the only thing that woke me
up dude was your the beeping the texts
weren't waking me up the calls weren't
waking me up it was that [__] it was
like an em a test from emergency
broadcast oh it was loud I know how loud
that sound is and I know it's startling
so I was like if he's anywhere near it
he's going to I thought the fire alarm
was going off I was like oh I got to go
down and get your mom and I was like oh
it's my [__] phone and then I looked
and there was like 70 texts from your
mom and about two from you no just one
from you that said yo where you at yeah
yeah yeah yeah I could tell you were not
worried you're a grown ass man dude like
you're you're a grown human B I'm not
and I don't drink so I don't lose my
faculties like that no and if I'm going
to take enough mushrooms to end up
wandering around the streets I'm going
to take it around other people so I have
a buddy system yeah you people that's
why you don't do drugs by yourself
unless you have the buddy system I like
I I don't like doing drugs by myself
yeah but you always have safe ways home
and like back door like you're in a
controlled environment like you know
what I mean yeah that but buddy system
is very important ladies and gentlemen
always do drugs with a friend